as we did it happen actually just
yesterday in the election Colorado
they're gonna start taxing weed now and
you know it's already recreationally
legal there and it's I think also got
voted in it in Portland Oregon yesterday
so good stuffs happening in the weed
department and an according to a new
report that was obtained by The
Huffington Post legal marijuana is among
the fastest growing markets in the
United States and it's growing at a rate
posed to outpace the expansion of the
global market in smartphones and did I
just say that backwards I think I said
that slightly backwards anyway
researchers surveyed hundreds of medical
cannabis retailers processors dispensary
owners and industry leaders over six
months to a year researchers estimated
that more than one point four three
billion worth of legal marijuana will be
sold in 2013 that figure is expected to
grow by sixty four percent to two point
three four billion next year
by comparison recent figures show the
smartphone market expanded by forty six
percent from 2012 to 2013
I'm gonna go out on a limb here and say
you guys are pleased with this and that
there's no problem with the level of I
have stock in Funyuns so I am very happy
you're very very happy about this I
don't personally partake in the legal or
illegal you know drugs but I can confirm
that we were at a party yeah and I saw
you just say no I did I'm not saying
anything about myself you and everyone
had their clothes on they just say no
yeah but it was saying no because this
Saudi chick wanted to drive that's what
I was talking about I don't know if you
yeah but yeah I I think that if we can
tax this are we are we taxing this yeah
yeah so we California needs to tax this
desperately we need to take this
marijuana money and put it into our
schools so that our kids can know
marijuana gave me an education but I
mean I think that we need to definitely
grab on to some of that so
lot of money and I think it should be
legal and I think it should I don't
think these should dispensary should be
you know shut down because federal
people all of a sudden come in and go
hey wait a second we know it's legal in
your state but we're kind of we don't
like the fact that you guys are making
money and we don't anything to do with
it so we're gonna shut it down yeah just
to spite you so just to clarify that so
that's actually what's happening now so
even in California where every we could
walk out of here and go within a mile we
could probably find five pot
dispensaries it's legal here in
California but the feds do come in
sometimes
yeah and seize everything take all the
money shut the place down and all that
is this just one of these things sort of
like gay rights where as equality comes
around people realize oh it didn't
destroy straight marriage it didn't
destroy the army everything's okay and
as weed gets legalized people realize
didn't do that much bad stuff well
that's a key issue I mean as this
younger population ages and they start
voting I mean marijuana just isn't to
these young people what it is to older
folks now and if you really look at
research the most research doesn't point
to any kind of negative effect that
marijuana has on at the human body
they're just kind of speculating that
there's a problem and to be really
really frankly serious about marijuana
there are some huge health benefits and
people especially people who are
battling cancer I have a mother who has
ovarian cancer and marijuana has been
shown to actually shrink the size of
tumors stop the blood flow to tumors and
that's a huge issue and if we can get in
on that make money off of that attacks
that and have no negative side effects
that you know some of the medications
that we have for treating cancer along
with it that is huge and if just to talk
about the money itself I think if you
talked to any dealer they could have
told you how much money was actually in
marijuana you ask them and then all of
that going back into our system rather
than you know somewhere here or there
and everybody can look at stuff there
the fighting on the border with your
drug cartels and all that I think what
Beth is saying is you know with the
marijuana helping it health-wise if you
like your weed you can keep your weight
right I think that's really what that's
illegal yeah if you like your weed you
can keep you know whatever you're
calling it you're cush cush cush she's a
very cushion that can you imagine if the
legalization of marijuana threatened gay
marriage oh and we came full circle we
fought
so hard you know for equality cake
marriage I and then it just ah
if legalizing weed was gonna cause gay
marriage I'd be okay
is part of this though the reason that
it's taking so long with we sort of just
the cliche thing about weed is when you
smoke it you're a little lazier so it's
like the audience know they're playing
video games and you know playing hacky
sack so you know it's hard to like get a
real grassroots Lobby no pun intended
grass think about the people who are you
know in their 30s and 40s right now
they're part of the just say no
generation they're part of the Nancy
Reagan you know enforcing the different
kind of lingo they have that kind of in
their heads that it's a bad thing it's
gonna be a gateway drug to other drugs
and yeah that's where the thought
process is but this younger generation
is coming in with this idea that there
are all kinds of health benefits what
are you making the gateway drug thing I
find that to be the stupidest possible
thing because it implies somehow that if
you took weed away that nobody would get
in no runs but you would just start at a
harder drug right I mean isn't it just
and that you thing would be cocaine
would be the gateway well I mean I ate
glue as a child and everyone said that's
the gateway but you just I know
so what go so the Gateway theory is
there was something there guys there was
something there but because I ate glue I
forgot what I was talking about yeah at
the end of the day to make this really
happen do we need Big Pharma to get
behind it like ya know we're gonna make
bars for sure but no do we need because
the drug the prescription drug companies
that give us all these drugs that make
us have suicidal thoughts and diarrhea
hmm you know that's you want to talk
about your morning every commercial half
the commercials about that stuff right
right
but that we that they're gonna try to
stop weed as much as possible because
they can't have some sort of naturally
growing that's gonna do all those good
things I thought you're saying get them
involved like get them behind it no no
that but okay to make it to really make
it legal because of all the power they
have yeah they're gonna somehow steal
the Thunder behind this thing
things would be as if the if the voters
if the population made it so that you
don't elect people who are really really
against it and then Big Pharma doesn't
have to get involved because they're not
going to have the power like turn this
is a very idealistic view but turn the
power back to the people let the voters
make the decision and then everybody
else is gonna have to have to catch up
and these people who are already doing
it are gonna be on the forefront of it
and they're gonna end up making a lot of
the money and maybe some of the power
will go away from big farm that's what's
happening right now but that that's Big
Pharma's fear so I feel like
automatically just because of the amount
of money they have they're gonna somehow
get in on this and screw it up listen
you want to get your weed from some guy
named dirt man Sam who lives in Venice
Beach who you have to literally like go
underneath in a basement in a crawl
space to get to his apartment and that's
where you want to get your weed you
don't want to walk into a save on or a
CVS and get your wheat that takes out
all the you know fun out of it this
coming from someone whose own who
doesn't smoke weed you know people get
their weed is how everyone got it here
all the people working here oh damn
glaucoma they have a cards doors I
really I really hope that it does find
some sort of middle ground it doesn't
get too big farm I don't want it to get
to that place but I don't want it just
to be kind of gross and back alley and
you know gunfights
right you know I mean with cartels that
it just you know stays but like you said
in the people's hands like with that one
hot nurse who wears a white lab coat on
Venice Beach telling you to come in if
you have a headache right she's
qualified
no no one doing I'm talking about we're
getting our weed buying advice from the
girl who doesn't smoke tell me haven't
seen that chicken a white lab coat on
Venice Beach
Ellen hot yes yes yes oh we're gonna
take a little field trip we gotta go
down right now all of us
you